[Music]
and got Johto newest submitted by
Cinnabons a human tote that was used for
a cocktail at a Canadian bar has been
stolen what the luck why are you using a
huge hole for a puppet
isn't that cannibalism also more because
I picture the worm at the bottom of a
tequila except it's a toe yes pretty
much one what do they get this dirty
toll and I don't think that cemetery
right whose toll is that is that the
bartender so Canada what the [ __ ] I'm
almost sure that has to be like the
owner's toe why is there a toe
oh it water was just as a display and
they weren't serving out of it no like
people it's a cocktail wait wait wait so
like at the end of the drink that they
suck and eat the toe or like are you
supposed to give it back this is the the
rule it says drink it fast or drink it
slow but your lips must touch the toe so
this is what the cocktail McKnight's
that is [ __ ] gross call this our toe
10 I've done that a million times that
is a [ __ ] huge tall human toe a real
human toe but now it's gone missing
oh my god to get decayed that is [ __ ]
me maybe somebody ate it because they're
too drunk that has happened in the past
we find multiple homes what do they get
on and what kind of flavor does it bring
out in the street oh you're beautiful
it's like the wrong question oh yeah
whoa no because it's just like if they
keep getting new toes is like it must
have a very distinct flavor I'm pretty
sure it's not whatever luck it's
probably for the novelty I don't want a
what as waiver but that's clearly this
is agent oh it's a little spicy you had
a little mung bean package is not going
to like this Thank You tokuji I know
like oh and I get the black versus
Copley's weird so this cocktail is being
served at the downtown hotel in Dawson
City in Yukon Canada so North Canada
you can't go yes and so the drink is
called a sourdough
so there's a masculine tradition claims
is Contrave its roots back to the 1920s
when they claimed that there was this
rum runner that had his toe frostbitten
so he preserved his toe in a bottle of
rum and so he kept it in the cabin that
they had commute on he never really
accepted in the bottle of rum I really
don't know why I have my wisdom teeth
like that relate to that 50 years later
the pickle toe was found by yukon native
who bought the cabin so they forgot but
though yeah he left a lot of things
behind but the toe was there and so
finally that's when that natives took it
to a downtown hotel and they just said
hey while we just create a cocktail and
originally the cocktail was a beer mug
full of champagne and then the place was
telling their toenail clippings at the
top that was short-lived because
apparently there was someone that said
like I don't care about the co but I
can't down an entire mug full of
champagne like this yeah yeah so then
they ended up switching it up and now
there's just pretty much your alcohol of
choice the tilde is hole so it after
you're done you take the toe out and
someone up and he put it in someone
else's drink
yeah pretty much so they have a 2-hour
window of when they serve this drink and
so they're saying that this recent toe
they had just started adding it to the
drinks but there was this man that went
to the hotel he asked the waitress his
new waitress if they can create this
cocktail for him even though it was
outside of the two-hour window and so
she was being nice so she made it for
him and it also awarded him with the
sour toe cocktail certificate with his
name on it
but this dude she took the toe and he
left the certificate behind so they have
his name but they still can't find him
for whatever reason so they're doing
anyone a wallet how or did they get the
human tongue why would he get the human
toll from it's been donated because they
know I know of this cocktail so people
were like oh I had my toe amputated he
really has
yeah this is just changed the bar to
like body-part bar so you can get famous
cocktail the ball [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
cocktail cocktail should do all of them
you've got a cocktail please the actual
one or the drinks what would you like if
they're donating amputated toes like
then there must be something wrong with
that toe so why would you drink
something that has whatever be
frostbitten or like other things - well
they also cure it - so take think about
like this most we like a rotten tool
yeah it took about six months in salt
for it to be like the hydrated fully and
they can use well we mummify it
basically honeydew yeah that's why I
look like this no rope he's not
borderline cannibalism yeah that's one
thing about I think it's one of those
things where it's like I dare you Yeah
right there you can't do it I do it you
want to do it I can do it come on I'm
good man again you win number one I
don't like hard liquor that much in the
first place
so that on top of what the human tone it
I'm good I feel like you're on even if
I'm drunk I'll be even what I'm drunk I
still have you know my wits about me
somewhat somewhat enough to know that
I'm not going to [ __ ] put a human toe
to my [ __ ] face
I don't like a living toe near my
[ __ ] mouth back in 2013 a man
accidentally oh and then he's choked to
death they've gone through eight toes
since they started this tradition that
tells me to quit you know what white
people you win I feel like the person
that started this it was like you know
all those agencies are so badass you
doing that chicken feet and the duck
feet wheels weak toes I know they went
up this hard we will not do that crazy
[ __ ] man it captained Italy exactly
Captain James and captain Tran captain
Lee or captain Kim those captain human
dick big that's so crazy I can't even do
the [ __ ] worm like that where I learn
my Oh Y worm is that the port of what we
look at a pair of spiders what's the
catch I don't I know there's probably
this tradition behind it but I'm just
like mouse transistors oh no we got like
Tiger ball whiskey and [ __ ] - so we're
not working it's Tiger balls yeah it's
supposed to be like for viagra
really no names no stay fodder that if
you drink Tiger balls or whatever to get
your dick hard
yeah this makes no sense at all
whatsoever well cuz they thought that
any body part will make your body part
better if you put the eyeball liner
you're visually going to get their eye
mom always told me to eat the fish I
maybe made a word yeah tiny science
right any size big those they just want
a big dick son here is Tiger dick yeah
it's almost like that anyway like
bullshitting through the answer and just
became a fact you know I mean how can I
get a strong dick tight against the
cable I was in history did you see the
Andrew Z's food bizarre foods of him
going to that China restaurant where
everything is dick all a condom value
was no no no it's it's a restaurant I
think it's in Beijing oh yeah yeah yeah
everything there is dick yeah yeah and
what animals all kinds of animals oh
it's a dick buffet yeah yeah it's like a
sausage fest yeah that [ __ ] had
beaten so much dick like he could tell
like which dick keeper first yeah
because you don't want someone like the
the younger dick is too short and too
hard and rubbery some of the bigger ones
are a lot more soft it's like oh god no
but he can't eat spam I know right or
walnuts
he had a walnut he freaked the [ __ ] out
I like literally the scene before he ate
a [ __ ] dick yeah we ate what can dish
come oh [ __ ] all right yeah and we
should come all the time yeah all the
time
Abbot arse cod roe or cotton yeah Bally
it all the time it's delicious yeah an
acai
I don't know it's weird to me because I
feel like I can totally eat like female
stuff like eggs or whatever but then
when it comes to like common dick I
think about it I'm like does this make
me gay if I enjoy that body part do you
think it'd be different if you up on it
Oh could you grew up on it oh yeah yeah
I don't know maybe I mean eggs are
delicious oh I think Mooney is a co
crisper is it I think it's I think it's
a male body part oh well it's the
ambiguous blockers legs because they're
not there's a female male on
it's the gonads well I guess the ball
sack that is the balls
yeah that's not part of us yeah the
gonads are they creatures of the both I
think so like a word I'm not from Nike
yeah that's the classy laziness it's a
lot you have to say it in that society
you will come as a dieter there's so
many creatures in the world and they're
all delicious except human being down
dude I'm pretty sure humans taste good I
mean just from like scientifically
speaking Lea speaking man they stab it
don't like what you oh yeah don't move
much too seriously yeah dude straight up
me dude I'm pretty sure like there's
like marbled areas of my body that are
absolutely amazing
David Bacon hello how much would you
guys say some get David son get David
okay not to eat you really watching here
you smell it what is this what is this
the but just serves your piece you just
ate David and I move you in the hospital
that got you [ __ ] oh man anyway so
they're saying that they are offering a
reward to anyone that has any
information about to do this [ __ ] toe
feeding [ __ ] they don't mention how
much the award is but they do mention
those are back in 2013 when the man
swallowed the toe they had a five
hundred dollar fine but then because of
that guy they upped it to two thousand
five hundred so once they find this
through that fill the dough he's going
to find animal do they want the original
toe back or they just want to toast
owner no so the original toe seven years
after they started this cocktail back in
1971 so seven years after that um there
was this minor that accidentally saluted
but then this 2013 guy he rolled it over
bit oh gotta [ __ ] swallow toes all
day they said drug it should be their
first drink at that American I have to
kiss it too I saw like the video of
people taking the shot and so they just
kind of like open it a little bit so I
drink the alcohol and then the social is
alerts and then comes out the side we
had back in 2013 when this dudes
purposely swallowed it he was filming
that whole thing and so you can see like
you open is melt like why do it and then
it just
like that cool guy cool all of it is yep
you're captain of the fraternity now
brown Nestle stupid cool guy go to hell
your toes stealing [ __ ] thanks for
watching just kidding news guys don't
forget to comment down below we want to
hear what you say only if it's positive
remember that to watch more videos go up
here baby